recently mattel maker of the board game
scrabble
announced that players could no longer
use racial slurs to score points in the
game
they specifically said no slurs against
black
pakistani and irish people now a lot of
professional scrabble players are upset
about the rule change oh god damn it
okay
andy why are you angry this is clearly a
good thing
conan i play scrabble professionally
and while i agree wholeheartedly about
not using slurs about
black or pakistani people 90 percent of
my wins come from using slurs against
the irish
wait that's impossible how many irish
slurs could there possibly be
well just off the top of my head there's
uh mick
patty [ __ ] spudchugger dublin dork
sod humper tater filleter potato punter
lepreclown that's a good one whiskey
[ __ ]
tuber goober oh baby maker blarny [ __ ]
uh guinness guzzler freckly fondler
four-leaf clover cuck melon and depleted
dip [ __ ] wait man hold on andy
most of these have way too many letters
to be played as a scrabble word you only
get
seven tiles at a time uh tile counting
turf slurper
uh carrot top liver killer peat moss
gobbler
boston baked bastard uh tater tater
toucher tater mater
all right great we get it we get it pork
sucker uh pasty waste
cabbage head spud dud conan phase oh
that's just my name
you know what we have a great show gal
gadot is gonna be joining us we'll be
right back that's enough andy
frecklefracker [ __ ] simmons uh mrs
o'leary's trial that one doesn't even
make sense
um red-haired mediocrity